Et Jordan barbella,
et ce duel, c'est celui de la com,
c'est celui des slogans, des affichages,
c'est celui de la surface, mais
qui intéresse les français ?
Ce qui intéresse les agriculteurs,
c'est la
réalité en profondeur de ce qu'ils vivent au quotidien.
Et de ce pendule-là, il y a,
je crois que nous qui ayons
travaillé pour les
agriculteurs au cours du dernier mandat,
et il y a aujourd'hui que nous qui fassions des
propositions solides
pour pouvoir répondre aux
problèmes qu'il se pose tous les jours.
Moi, je. Je crois que les français,
et notamment les agriculteurs, qui, je le redis,
sont des gens qui travaillent dur
et qui veulent regarder la réalité des choses,
sauront faire la différence à la fin
entre les artifices de communication,
la mise en scène permanente et la réalité de l'action.
Et cette réalité de l'action,
c'est celle qu'on leur propose
aujourd'hui de partager avec eux.